die akten himmel herrschaft
entschuldigung es ist passiert herrgott
moment ist links ja ich war schon was
wahrscheinlich sagen ja freitag den
13ten muss sich nicht wundern wenn so
etwas passiert
sorgen um ein freitag der 13 ist ein tag
wie jeder andere auch der basierten
gestimmt und um das zu beweisen habe ich
heute unsere außenreporterin veronika
bergmann an den gefährlichsten ort
bayerns geschickt in die hellenthaler
schlucht über ihre tonnenschwere
gesteinsbrocken die sie jederzeit lösen
können und mir ja einige hundert meter
abgrund stehen auf einem 20 zentimeter
breiten glitschigen in den fels
gehauenen steg ohne sicherung und ohne
alles da frisst und dann schalten wir
mal in die hölle noch zu frau bergmann
falls sie noch nie probiert man können
sie mich hören frau bergmann hören sie
mich hallo ja logisch kann ich sie hören
oder denken sie ich bin taub nicht aber
durch
frage haben sie ist gemütlich ganz
gemütlich der eco schlägt komisch die
hüllen paul schluck bier gar nie so
glücklich und kuschel liegt vorgestellt
die hölle schlucht herr grünwald
wirklich dämlich auf sie diese frage
nicht beantworten ich jedoch einen
freitag den 13 an den gefährlichsten ort
bayerns ja das war aber ihr job frau
bergmann dann nimmst du noch hin ich bin
schließlich noch jung ich habe noch
nicht mit dem leben abgeschlossen wie es
die alter knacker ich bleibe heute
daheim frau bergmann sie haben beim
bayerischen rundfunk einen vertrag
unterschrieben papperlapapp aber nur mit
zaubertinte ich mein ich möchte den
heutigen tag doch überleben ich bleib
heute zuhause ich gehe nirgendwo hin
noch nicht einmal in den keller ich
bleibe genau hier sitzen und ich esse
auch nichts was nahe dran am
haltbarkeitsdatum ist
überhaupt nichts essen und auch nichts
trinken frau bergmann wirst du alles
reiner aberglaube statistisch gesehen
passieren am freitag den 13 sogar
weniger unfälle als an anderen tagen ist
wenn du die idioten rausgehen frau
bergmann sie wissen aber schon dass die
meisten unfälle zu hause passieren was
ja wirklich zu hause passiert mit großem
abstand die meisten unfälle
dann muss ich sofort heraus und wo ist
es am sichersten also an alle aller
sichersten ist in der höllental schluss
[Musik]
frau bergmann was ich sage zu hause
passieren die meisten unfälle
denn er gern beim aufräumen helfen wir
uns
mit dass man uns passiert grün weil sie
vollidiot sie dicker als rechts
ausgeblendet
[Applaus]